that's great here
yeah
coffee
I think she's a coffee
so I'm back home Michael
you
you
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club with over $30,000
and pride on the line 20 international
chess professionals converge in st.
Louis for the 2018 spring chess classic
[Music]
we're racing to the finish line here at
the 2018 spring chess classic the
penultimate round hello my name is Ben
Simon and I have Italian aimer and while
things look like they are shaping up
pretty clearly a group a group b is a
whole nother question altogether Vitali
we're gonna be in for maybe some
fireworks today oh yeah definitely I you
know it's the last two rounds that we
got left and many things are going to be
decided today and I expect a lot of
violence on the chess board today oh
dear well let's take a look at what
happened last night
in round number seven right before these
last two events group a up first
yeah so we had the Pharaohs in Group A
Alex initially drew down as well as
yellow gel drew against Ramon Edouard
Jeffrey John drew against Sam chenkin
but we did have two decisive results
Lazaro Brazil beat with the black pieces
- yeah Ganguly and vara Cobian beat with
the black pieces against other sleep it
off so looks like they're that that
color is doing much better than being
white yeah it's an unusual event and
Verico pians went does put him before
going into the day at four points in
clear second behind Jeffrey Zhang and
remember there are no playoffs in this
event
so Jeffrey Zhang has a pretty easy path
there I say to at least a clinching a
tie for first and we'll look more at
that in just a moment but then everyone
else is a three and a half into a night
oh yeah the second place and I thought
place we still don't know who's gonna
take it still everything is very open
right and now the results last night
from Group B yes of all pretty much
similar results we had three draws
Pedro against Andre medication joy
against Alexander fear Jax tembu luck
drew against Aaron Levinsky and the
victor metal f ski defeated action
Chandra with white pieces jg mirandy
lost through a Wonder Liang indeed
makovski getting his third victory in a
row and that brings us to our standings
before today victim if I have ski is on
the top of five points as we say he's on
fire with three wins and behind him just
slide over his shoulder we see Malik
player shot and Andre with four and a
half points it's gonna be a close match
this is really one of those situations
where you're kind of like oh group B I
wish we did get a playoff right yeah
definitely ties there at the top after
nine rounds have been played and now
going on right now at us chest champs
calm it's Group A and two of these games
have already ended I'll tell you
straight away that Varco bian and Surya
Ganguly have drawn their game as well as
Alex owner shook and ero juror book they
have drawn their game as well by Talia
yeah so nothing much changes on the
standings list and the game of the day
the one to watch should be pretty simple
here Jeffrey Zhang is looking to clinch
either a clear victory or a at least a
tie for first
oh yeah definitely I if Jeff Lee wins
that's that's pretty much it that the
first place is his however a man Edward
you know ken you probably will try to
beat him with the white pieces and
that's the violence and was talking
about before so who and the games going
on in Group B happening right now only
one of these has ended Akshat Chandra
and JJ Ali morandi have drawn their game
the other four games are still active
that's what man this thing to see what's
gonna happen the game of the day to
watch in this division has to be
priyadarshan canna pan taking on mythic
hockey on two of the top leaders here in
Group B yeah it looks like a PD is doing
well so far without any low
so I think that the medic will try to do
his best
do you have any other predictions for
this round yeah I think I think we're
gonna see some fireworks on the on the
chessboard lovely I mean I think we will
do I think it's a pretty fair thing to
predict the tournament format is as
follows we are finishing up to ten
player round robins 90 minutes for the
first 40 moves on the clock and then
after 40 moves an additional 30 minutes
is added to each player's clock there is
a 30-second increment from move number
one and there are no draws allowed
before move 30 this is to encourage
fighting chess and as we said of course
it could be a big factor unfortunately
there are no playoffs in this event the
schedule is as follows today we're
starting a little bit earlier hope you
joined us in time 11:00 a.m. was win the
round itself started central time and
now we're joining you here at 1:30
tomorrow it will be the same deal for
the final round 11:00 a.m. the round
starts and we'll be on the air at 1:30
with you the closing ceremony is not
broadcast and now let's take a look at
the prizes this is what's all on the
line $22,000 total prize fund in Group A
yeah it's for the amazing $22,000 the
first place we'll take $6,000 $4,000 for
the second place and $3,000 for the
third place and even the last place will
get a thousand bucks and six grand has
Jeffrey Jones name written all over and
I'm not even worried about jinxing
Timothy and the prize fund for groupie
14 grand total on the line yeah with the
first with the top place taking home
four thousand dollars twenty five
hundred and two thousand dollars for the
second and a third place and even the
last place will take five hundred
dollars with him lovely Italian let's
take a look at some of the games the
game of the day in Group A we have Roman
Edouard and Jeffrey Zhang with two
grandmasters going at it and this is
gonna this is it's all on the line
exactly that's it that's see some some
of that violence as we discussed before
Jeffrey Zhang I guess ed
Ramon Edward let's look at the current
position right now it looks like pretty
equal with equal position the definitely
wants white played this last move in the
game rook to f8 I hope the f1 is trying
to exchange the rooks so let's try to
see what's gonna happen after the
exchange of the rooks basically Roman is
going to try probably transpose himself
into some kind of an endgame now with
the Queen's of the board it's very
unclear what is going to happen here at
the board
however if white succeeds in exchanging
the Queen's I think that the pawn
structure just because the fact that
white pawns are all non white squares
will give some chances to for white now
it's not no it's definitely not winning
for for sure but I do like the knight
chances are definitely you know in the
chess game the knight can go to all of
the squares in the other chest what he
can get there well the the bishop can
only get two today two squares kind of
kind of a disadvantage so yeah it'll be
interesting to see what the players are
going to play they are at move number 29
this move rotates if one is has not been
played yet but this is kind of what I
expect to see they take I wonder if
black also white is attacking this pawn
on c7 by the way so black will probably
need to defend it somehow either with
the Queen to d6 or Bishop to d6 probably
with the bishop would be more of a
straight forward away and I think that
here Y could probably tell suppose the
screen somewhere maybe 23 Queen f3
someone on the F file so we probably
might we might see something like this
variation check King G to the B King G
one
we might see some exchange of Queen's if
if black decides to exchange and this
might be a very long game by the way
because of this endgame yeah we'll see
usually as we said according to you know
to gently look at his past games he was
playing much better with black so we
will see if right all of his games that
he won were with black right so so we'll
see if he can win this one as well
however I don't think it's gonna be so
easy in this position yeah it is my
opinion that this game if it does go
later I think we should probably stay
with it as long as we can I mean this is
this is could decide the tournament
right here yeah yeah definitely
even even a draw in this situation a
draw will guarantee that Geoffrey will
at least tie for first so he will clinch
first no matter what maybe a tie a win
will clinch sole first yeah let's go to
the game of the day in Group B in Group
B we have Pierre - on canna pan against
Malik kutcheon all right let's look at
this position looks like Malik has the
time advantage 26 extra minutes 25 if
extra minutes on the clock which can
make a huge impact as you know pretty
much most of the games that we have seen
in this chess tournament most of the
time people blunder in time pressure so
that might be a huge game changer so
let's look at let's look at our board
right now actually we have 41 so let's
see so Knight to d5 was just played by
player - and Kenna pan so this came out
from probably from the dragon defense
let's look at how what what was the
opening a 45 93 93 and g6 this is what
we call the dragon Bishop III Bishop g7
and f3 Castle and Queen d2 so the idea
for what is that white wants to castle
long side this is what we call the
Yugoslav attack and this is one of the
most challenging for
against the the dragon that we have here
the idea for what will be pushing up his
pawns on the h4 h4 g4 basically rolling
all over the H file then coming here
with a Bishop h6 and you know basically
penetrating blacks defenses so let's see
what happened 96 castle and Bishop to e6
as far as I remember Bishop d7 is more
of a other line that they can play also
white sometimes plays Bishop to c4 but
this is there are lots and lots of teal
and in those openings I'm sure that both
of the players came prepared and to play
usually the dragon games they don't end
in a draw we have lots of decisive
results just because of the nature of
the game we have opposite side casting
which means that both of the players so
we'll try to attack each other on both
of the side so the white is going to be
trying to attack on the Kings side but
h4 and G fo black is going to try to
attack on the Queen side B 5 and a 5 and
that's going to be a race it's exciting
game yeah it's good let's see who's
gonna make who first and so a few
moments got well made Queen comes to a 5
a 3 & a penalty here why decided that I
want to exchange some Queens let let's
put the plush shot down a little bit
like Queen takes d2 and rook takes t2 so
really in this moment the the game is
changing its face to some kind of an
endgame
not exactly endgame yet but we
definitely won't see those made threats
again so rooks if I was playing knife
they went back we have a few pawn
potions over here at 497 and 925 so
obviously white wants to take you on a 7
good night Black has to figure out do I
take this night with a bishop although I
want just to defend this this pawn
somehow and with maybe quick came to f8
or maybe somehow with the rook I would
say that this Knight is a pretty strong
piece on d5 I would consider strongly to
to take it on d5 as you can see from our
video broadcast it looks like play of
the ocean is pretty relaxed over the
game and Medicaid one who needs to do
most of the thinking but I have to I
have to point out that again this is
move number 21 was played which means
that the players have 19 moves to to
make until time control to get this
extra 30 minutes and in this case I mean
if we really might find himself in time
travel pretty soon pretty soon so let's
try this Bishop takes d5 pawn takes d5
okay why can't I take this this pawn on
d5 maybe this was a nice life that's why
he's preparing for Black Knight to c6
attacking this the rook and a 7/10 stri
to defend a 7 over the rock I do have a
feeling that like that white is the
pearls and tricks on traps over here
right now I see that oh I can just take
this pawn on a7 not one of the most I
would say tastiest pawns on the
chessboard the a7 pollen but still at
some point this will be become one of
the advantages for white maybe so it's
going to be interesting to see to follow
this to follow this game but as far as I
as far as I understand it's probably
closer to equal and I think that
production would be pretty happy with a
draw because that will put him to 5 and
a half if I'm not mistaken and medic is
gonna be with 5 points well pre darshan
right now has four and a half for five
right so you're gonna go to 5 and medic
is when we have four and a half so he
still is going to stay there at the top
on the other hand you know I gotta tell
you
I believe that they're both at four and
a half in interesting enough perhaps we
were looking at some oh yeah that was
Victor right yeah yeah
Victor was the only one who was dealing
with five points yes so so draw for them
you know there's still both are going to
stay at the top but you know maybe
somebody on the fifth place of sixth
place might win their games and share
their places as well so as far as I see
right now Malik did play made a move any
play this move King to f8 it's just
defending this pawn only seven and it is
going to be interesting to see why what
does why I do my first impression is
that my rookie on on the on f1 is
aligned with the king and I wondered can
I just try to play ff5 trying to open up
this the F file over the king and maybe
also trying to play f6 or take on g6 on
the other hand if I do play a five I am
going to give like this the square one
on e5 for the night which I might not do
but overall I I mean I think that I like
White's position slightly slightly more
solid all of these pieces are well
placed yeah it's gonna be it's gonna be
coming to an end game skill and this in
this game let's see one of the one of
the other games that I wanted to look at
which was a SEM Shanklin versus
Alexander Apatow
well if I tell you we have a result in I
just see right now that Roman Edouard
and Jeffrey Zhang have drawn their
gaming on a and this means that Jeffrey
Zhang has guaranteed himself at least a
tie for first place and we are most
likely to decide the top spot in the
tournament in this round we won't even
have to think about tomorrow we'll still
be here tomorrow of course all the games
will be played
yeah but yet congratulations to Jeffery
Zhang who will be in first place
maybe alone and maybe with another yeah
good job to Jeffrey he was leading the
whole tournament he was playing very
well especially with it with the black
so yeah so that is not not surprising
we've had an interview with his dad we
know how much effort and hard work we is
putting into chess and all of his family
is putting into chess and believes in
him
so congratulations now I would like to
save the winners interview so to speak
for tomorrow our big main event day I
think we should talk to Grandmaster
Romana édouard definitely we haven't
spoken to him yet
yeah and then he's from from fronts if
I'm not mistake yes the only French
player in this term one of the best
players in France yeah did you know that
in high school I used to take French for
three years and I got to know the only
thing I know how to say is Jeanette
parlez-vous francais which means I don't
speak French that's a good thing so
hopefully hopefully probably one knows
some English and there we can we can
interfere or we could just sit here in
silence yeah yeah it'll be great to talk
to so yeah so they drew their game so
right now I wonder who can who can tie
the match with with Jeffrey so Jeffrey
has fought only bar olive our only bar
bar is well hold on check that ba has
finished his game with a drum that's not
yeah there are still some games that
have not finished that the players at
three and a half so it's a really long
shot Jeffrey would have to lose tomorrow
for some of the S has to whist or win so
yeah it's most likely bars looking bars
looking at it but but Jeffrey is
guaranteed himself first place
good job good job for him I wanted to go
back to this game that they want to
discuss Alexandra epitope and playing
against Sam Shanklin and I gotta tell
you about this game okay okay so I go
into the tournament hall and getting the
shots of the players at the beginning of
the round and Shanklin
has played d4 first move yeah
okay let's get that for up there okay I
think special and normally you know you
have your D for your C for players and
and you have some kind of idea what
you're gonna play on move number one is
black five-and-a-half minutes
Alex eepa table sat there really grossly
intent on figuring out what he was gonna
play yeah against this D for Edie people
were walking by like what's going on
here you know it was clocks up
everything's right and then he plays
Knight 86 no way this move 96 what is
that Barco viens coming by the board
he's yeah wasn't it vegetable they touch
the neither Sun no it was definitely
with intent he wanted to play 96 Wow
their slap that clock so epitope you
know look he's not in contention he I
don't know what's he doing today try
something crazy I know I know that's
that's all I was saying I mean they they
they need to try the chances I mean III
think it was probably not the
preparation definitely right because
they were thinking for five minutes out
otherwise he would just play it
immediately with nine a six with the
confidence but nine a six you know I've
never seen this such a movie you know in
definitely not in one of my games yeah
that that's a good question you know I
was I can't can't remember the the name
of this opening if there is such an
opening but this type books they're so
awkward and I don't know maybe a maybe I
can call it the drunk night defense I
like it
let's go with it the drunken night
defense all right I dig it
yeah so so we will see how this night it
goes you know what happens to him over
there so let's see what why played if I
played c4 it looks like white said okay
I don't care about this move I just
placed before obviously the other move I
would consider here for white is just e
for right if the opponent allows us to
control the center with both of the
points this is pretty much what we are
going to do now the question is what
would Alex on the epitope will do next
because if if Fleck tries to play
something like I don't think even though
it's it's kind of a strange position but
let's try to play
maybe c5 maybe that was the idea to buy
96 but then white can take this this
night with a bishop and even destroy
black structure so I quite can't can't
understand you know what is going on
here what's the idea of this this move
on 96 and all the time I think I've seen
such moves maybe in blitz game so maybe
like some bughouse games but yeah
interesting interesting idea 96 c4 was
played and I'm be 5 wow I wonder how
much time Aleksandra able to spent on
this move on e5 it just sacrifices upon
very very creative obviously pawn takes
and now d6 you sacrifice another pawn
what is going on here white said okay
that's it I I don't want to take this
pawn here I just prefer to develop my
vision my pieces neither f3 and now
Bishop to f5 very interesting clay here
bye-bye white and now Bishop to went to
g5 Queen d7 93 and pawn takes only 5
they did exchange the Queen's and white
took on e5 so it looks like what is just
a pawn up but sometimes white does have
some difficulties so for example now
black wants to play this move f6 Bishop
f4 and long castle very interesting
sacrifice by Alexander epitope is a pawn
down but definitely the idea of this
night here is to come to before and to
come to c2 so let's see what happens
here III 9 f6 we should be to Bishop to
b4 okay Castle Bishop takes c3 and
Knight to e4 so what black has achieved
is some kind of a positional I won't say
advantage but I would say a compensation
and looking at this those double pawns
here on the C file rook F c1 was played
route to d2 a very active game by
Alexander
Bishop f3 + f5 that's why that's why I
call violence you know just all the
pieces coming together
Bishop going back to g3 rook a to d8
Bishop H for Rudy succeed is just I
really like his style of play he's just
going forward all the time no backward
moves Bishop e7 fish ought to be six
what did he want
ro to be - look at that that's such a
funny rock lift requested d8 the 6b 6b -
and probably now is going to go to D -
like yes question here is amazing yeah
so Bishop takes e4 white decides to
exchange a few pieces takes here takes
in King to f1 very interesting endgame
this night only six still feels a bit
uncomfortable you cannot go to c5 can go
to before because of the because of the
bishop here defending all those squares
so I wonder what what can we do about
this night so let's see what happened
night to be eight okay so that's the
first one that he went backwards he said
okay let's bring my knight back was
enough of a surprise element in this
game let's bring our knife back home row
C to D 197 was had to be played we
cannot take this policy three because of
checkpoint in one move 97 Knight takes
bishop takes root d4 and it is the let
me refresh the board let's see what
happened next
we stopped at look to d4 black took on a
to rook takes on e4 check with a few
checks and a5 I mean look at this
position it's amazing so black can
already secured a draw so we have seen
at this position before black check on I
want King D to check on it - King - you
want so if black wants to secure a draw
he can just continue checking white and
just repeat the moves but Alexander
says no I'm playing for the win I have
nothing to lose today and I play 85 I
have this passer here on the a file and
let's let's see how can you stop me I'm
to be honest I I would be quite scared
about this this disposition because
white is white is a pawn up but this one
is the only Paso that I see what but
it's really blocking it by his own
pieces and this this rook on the a2 is a
monster is a monster he's cutting off
the D King getting chaos on the on the
on the in his position
those two pawns C 4 and C 3 do not do
anything very big weaknesses and I just
wonder how can white play here in the
game white played rope to h4 trying to
go for those pawns let's try to accept
the fennel of the pond
let's say I play h6 white and probably
well I cannot play room G for attacking
the Jeep on because the bishop is
attacking on g4 so I would assume white
would try to do something like rook f4
to come to f8 and I probably need to
move my bishop or I can try to play b6
maybe a hide with the King I started to
make it give a check rook to g8 but I
wonder here ok you can take all of my
pawns but I wonder what would happen
with this pawn on on the a fire so take
and we'll play a tree and well if this
one with white can sacrifice this bishop
on a3 is that the only choice he has
yeah I mean it looks it looks this is
probably the best choice to stop this
pawn now in this case not only he is
going to 2nd is bishop but he's going to
get out of bishop back so but maybe
black needs to be a bit careful in all
those variations but I really like the
spirit of Alexander today very very
fighting spirit a place for for a win
and you know Knight this move 96 this
move a 5 it's all about the a files a
day for
so they are currently at move number
let's see the alle currently it move
number Tully
which leaves them ten ten more moves to
make time control both of them well Sam
has slightly more time with twenty five
minutes and that if someone has eleven
minutes so it's getting there it's
getting to the time pressure yeah
it'll be very interesting to see what
and he has played and I think he pushed
the a pond I think it was something on
the right side it looks like it yeah a
for my telly have you ever been in a
situation like HIPAA Tov where you're
it's late in the tournament and you
haven't been performing at your best and
you just throw it all out there you know
let's play crazy yeah yeah yeah
sometimes sometimes I do do that you
know just just for the fun of it but not
like with the move Knight a six that's a
head that's very creative of him yes but
now it gives me an idea
yes maybe I'll maybe I'll start with
Knight h6 I think that there is actually
an opening which is called maybe the
fried Fox if I'm not mistaking well
white plays f3 and then King f2 if I'm
not mistaken I don't know about that
yeah lots of lots of elements a
wandering King the wandering King
wandering yes favorite of Danny Machuca
a surprise weapon yes I think he
actually I think Danny Machuca are the
guy running the show here I think he
actually has a variant where you have to
play the wandering King I might be wrong
about that but yeah it's a crazy game
and everybody laughs it's not for me I
don't like that fun yeah I think to a
member yeah interesting so a foe was
played and let's see what's going on up
here so if white takes the spot of h7
what is the what is Black's idea so I
can again I can play a three
because the rotate shades and I have to
give up my bishop
maybe Queen d7 here by the way and I
might take one of your pieces back they
wrote all the bishop so let's let's go
back what else well we said that after
the bishop ate what can sacrifices
bishop so I assume that definitely
aleksandr saw this sacrifice so I cannot
just play a three here I would probably
have to move my bishop somewhere and to
be honest all of those squares looks at
look attractive for for for black see
six will attack the G to pawn f5 will
put him on this diagonal and attacking
the rook a six will be attacking the c-4
phone and so yeah this there's going to
be some kind of a bishop movement this
in this position I'm not not sure where
the bishop is going to go he might go to
yeah all those squares look very very
attractive so we will see what is going
to happen here we will come back to this
game let's look let's try to look at
some other games
what is interesting let's see a victim
cholesky and ruby versus Aaron Levinsky
Aaron's is playing with white pieces
let's see what has happened in the game
right now Aaron is looking pretty good
with two pieces for a rook however black
also has not only work but the rook and
two pawns
so it looks kind of equal kind of equal
to me but again looks like Viktor
Michalowski is in time pressure with
just four four points with Fulton so
it's over four minutes
it is going to be interesting to see
what what will be played in this
position it is it is white to move right
now as we as everyone remembers Aaron
rabbinic is a pretty fast player so what
can we do here I don't really want to
take on the fate because that's going to
just improve blacks black stroke okay
let's try to develop some pieces if I
play rook f1 I'm gonna lose the e4 pawn
I do not want to do that
so how do I defend the e4 pawn how do I
defend this pawn can I defend this point
that is a good question
clean DT was very good move may I played
my victim cholesky cannot see right away
and move for white to defend the pawn if
I try to defend with the Queen Queen
after your queen of war in this case
okay this might be actually the idea and
so if but I cannot take here on g5
because of Knight to f5 and we have this
interesting discovered I check on the on
the King here and winning winning the
Queen so it is going to be interesting
to see what what why would play if white
will play this move Queen to f3 and try
to try to win the game let's go
backwards let's try to look at this
position again again there they are and
move number 30 which gives them 10
minutes to finish well to get to the
time to the time control to get 30 more
minutes and this is definitely going to
be an exciting game although not the
game of the day however again victim may
collapse key is at the test the top seed
will probably try to get some points out
of this okay and now I would like to
welcome a guest to our show arrow man
Edward welcome how you doing good good
alright so you played the game of the
day
against Jefferson with the white with
the white pieces so first of all you are
from France right yeah yeah so how long
does it usually take to come to st.
Louis you know from um Europe just maybe
like two flights right actually it was
three flights around 20 hours okay
interesting so welcome here is it your
first time here and say bless yes okay
how do you how do you like it so far
it's very nice I mean very know how to
welcome welcome chess players and it's
really nice to play in this atmosphere
and we such good conditions so I'm
really happy here
yeah it's nice well welcome we actually
me and then we'll just discussion
discussion the conditions yesterday now
show yesterday and add the candidate
tournament if you were watching there
was an interview was done with Alexander
and he said something about you know the
toilet so we're very happy that you
helped the conditions here it's probably
better here than in Berlin from what I
heard at least yeah yeah welcome okay so
maybe we can discuss our new game today
against Jeff Lee I assume that you know
you came with this fighting spirit you
came to win of course but at some moment
I had to have to be a little a little
bit wise or whether I was gonna lose the
game you know okay so you started the
game with c4 the English defense yeah
and II five was that expected no
actually it was always playing c4 c5 so
if I've came as a surprise but I knew a
little bit what to do of course nice
yeah and yeah all we played until move
searching was some see really at least
until move tiny to the main line mm-hmm
so g3 Bishop Knight f6 it looks like a
as far as I'm aware this life is very
fashionable nowadays just to play to
immediately instead of Knight c3
yeah I mean now your body when you put
the knight on sister everybody is
playing Bishop before I move to three or
four
yeah and it's in general quite annoying
so I'm just playing g3 it's also it has
some disadvantages as well but well in
that game I open and played Knight f6
and d5 so we transposed into the
okay so Bishop d2 d5 take take I don't
know if you noticed but Jeff Lee
actually won all his games in this
tournament with black for my back so I
saw yes for three all three of the other
games yeah so I think just two black
pieces yeah it's a night of tea this is
pretty much old theory yes hey castle
Bishop e7 a 3/4 that's also the main
line Bishop e6 and now rugby one is like
supposed to be some clever move better
than these three the idea is just to
control the the BC square and for
example now if black plays a5 b5 94 the
pawn on e5 is hanging because there is
no Bishop d3 so you know this is a very
basic idea of this move from b1 f6 is
also the main line and I had this
position with the black pieces a few
months ago against gelfand and he played
b5 in III as I did in that game and well
I must say a first when I got it on the
board is black I said it looks it
doesn't look dangerous at all but then I
spent some 40 minutes thinking and I
realized that I have many moves but none
of them is really clear equality so yeah
I just decided to go for it actually I
also wanted to go for it two days ago
against various okay interesting yeah
it's it's actually an interesting point
so you actually play this position with
black as well which gives you some
insights you know from time to time and
I played it against girl phone here I
think I made movies d3 so I had some
idea what to do on the main moves and he
played b5 III which I had never seen so
well actually especially today that he
was spending quite a lot of time even
for last moves I thought well for sure
he will not know this ID and let's see
what you can write it's perfect so be
594 and then III and I thinks is that
what happened the game that except f3
and now there are many moves from like
the game we played night II fighter is
also Quincy eight right yeah well the
whole idea is that the opponent b7 is
is always a problem so here the main was
our self 95 Quincy 8 is also possible I
think the games I think some Russian
players played that position and then
after Quincy ad for Tate take Rudy 8 and
then c6 public interests it was always
slightly better for white quit i doing
to play for black against gelfand I
played rugby 8 but after D four we
played a great game and just somehow
crushed me so 95 is maybe the best move
and here as far as I know everybody went
Quincy - but against Galvan I didn't
play 95 because I was afraid of 92 which
which I played in the game like Ito yes
yeah it is just to play d4 to keep the
pieces on the board and to play d4 so he
replayed 27 I thought the only move was
have 5 actually to stop d4 and actually
it's maybe true
d4 no now therefore is he foreign is
just good for black so after F father
would not put it before I would play
Bishop b2 mm-hmm now black does not want
to pull too pushy for because after
Bishop g2 I get to next was an extra
square on d4 for my knight and I will
open the center with d3 right so I think
your Queen d6 for example and let's say
Queen c2 and there's somewhere I want to
play let's say e 4 or these 3 Bishop g2
and it's not so easy for black to to
know how to react oh well I don't know
if white is better here because I didn't
really check it deeply with computer but
okay yeah how far can you go right small
number 16 yeah I mean it's just all
afraid to play this position with black
fur so that's we'll play it with white
yeah actually it's a good tip for the
viewers you know it's home people are
watching us and actually know if
sometimes if you're playing an opening
and somebody's playing something against
you and you lose the game for example or
you feel uncomfortable then you can try
to use it as as you happen for the other
side and it's also very good you know
for lazy people to just repeat whatever
other people are doing
oh yeah to find an idea so yeah yeah
you're a queen D so now DeForest so well
I thought I should be slightly better
here because now black cannot push e4
and any time it takes on d4 of course is
worse
okay Rock the eight in the game Quincy -
now it's even better than if before
black takes on d4 now I can't even take
with the night because there is no nice
history King edge he played interesting
move and now probably Bishop g2 I
thought it was very strong this probably
should be two but maybe that was not the
best maybe I should play Bishop b2
instead what's the idea of just well - I
just want to play say I mean it's a safe
Square for the bishop and at some point
I want to take only five and I don't
want the bishop on us we to be hanging
okay I mean we shove g2 is definitely
very logical but somehow in the game I
think he had enough counter play so
maybe Bishop b2 was much stronger to
just you know force black to do
something now right yeah it cannot play
e4i because it takes and something no no
no before this night b6 it looks nice to
some space but in fact d5 with just
Bishop a tree for example and maybe then
96 96 or just f5 and Nikon d5 will be
weak black is completely fine here for
sure so so now I don't want to push it
for d5 so so quickly
- and Bishop aged free which I thought
was very bad in fact took on h3 e4
Knight b6 and here I realized that my
first study was to take the pawn on c7
but then I started to realize that I
probably can't take it so Queen c7 for
example Rock d7 I think and now for
example if Queen sees three with the
idea Queen f3
I think Queen h5 is very annoying just
attacking the knight only - and it's big
compensation I think Roxy 80 takes d4
somehow looks yeah all the business
coming together yeah another idea
instead of Queen c3 was Queen c2 because
if it is for NAFTA Knight f4 I'm winning
some material the Queen is trapped and
Queen g4 f3 in the 96 but here just work
c8
if if the Queen goes to the to the D
file I think just 84 and if for example
Queen a to let's say just IDI 494 Quincy
for EPS 3 Queen g5 and now it looks good
for white because it looks like I can
place my Knights wherever I wander in
fact there is no tactics I think black
is completely fine yeah it's not so
scary actually life is no yeah too much
of good squares yeah and this pollen
thief oh yeah I mean I can very quickly
so another option was to first take only
five and then take on c7 but first of
all one important thing to check was Rob
takes F to here oh yeah if Rock f2 then
wrote d1 and made the tf2 computer says
yeah yeah this is me yes I have to take
with the King rock f8 check it's pretty
scary Bishop a4 only move and EF for
Queen d7 at the analysis results it was
not enough for black but no not enough
Queen e7 sorry because here s FG 3 but
kim jiwon kim jiwon and if f3 Rock f2 or
maybe Rob takes f3 yeah and it's
probably not enough for black it looks
very frightening the 1027 and it's just
an expert on yeah and all the very thing
you know grandma's confessed that I
somehow miss this will be shot before I
thought I thought of the rock f8
something is wrong yeah human yeah but
then well Rob takes f2 is of course not
forced here there were many moves for
black and I think it told me that he was
considering Queenie six which is
actually very smart it's an extra point
for for white but lucky somehow very
active e1 sighs yeah I mean it's very
active and then I see four is coming if
I take on this island then Bishop c5
this positioner just don't like for ya
especially not in time travel because
maybe especially in time trouble and
well I think this position also switch
him I mean he's a Greenville player and
he's quite T because it just gave some
points and opened the position I mean I
really wanted to take this pawn on c7
but then I realized it is probably not
it's simply a poisoned pawn yeah okay so
you instead played Bishop to e3 right
okay that's nice nice developing move
yeah but now I think you again played a
great move Queen e6 he wants 94 and then
attacking just about twenty six computer
wants a for now a 494 looks good for
like yeah this might be five yeah please
I mean d5 is not a solution
I think then it's carrot I'm not better
but I simply could not find another move
again the pawn on c7 was hanging but
instead of d5 but then I think e d4 and
Queenie for and it's just a draw make
sense yeah with the without the bishop
energy tools you have some weaknesses of
the King as well yeah yeah I think I
mean again it's very frustrating this
bone is there hanging yeah you wanted
the fighting chess but he came fighting
propelled as well no I mean you really I
think you really played the brilliant I
mean this Bishop aged free is really
hard to find if he played the very fast
the opening no no no it no it simply
found great moves I think oh okay so
maybe now you can use it as white yeah
yeah like this black yes
so anyway deep five when I play d5 a
certain not better but a for f5 is just
in time F 324 King g2 now the pond on a4
is not hanging because I would have aged
free just chasing the black Queen and
then I would take the knight right but
she plays Queen g6 which was a coach
over because I missed this move and I
just really need to take on d5 and now I
really I just forced the draw playing
Bishop takes b6 because I saw the rest
is just slightly worse you know if I
don't take you house very easy play and
yeah rock a face will get fun I think
this is the one of the first positions
that I that I saw when we just started
our broadcast and I said that well he's
going to take actually I somehow I liked
white a bit more your chances here I
said if you exchange Queens maybe of
some some chances and I think as bishop
first of all I think even if I exchanged
Queen City just to later on and just put
the bishop to deceive the king of the
center I think it is just to draw and
second actually
here it is well I mean I think it is
white we should be a little careful
because the Bishop on c5 is very strong
mmm I mean it played actually here
suddenly I got afraid of Queen h6
instead of Bishop c5 but it's not
working because if the Queen gets to e3
and then Bishop c5 it can be it is just
very unpleasantly wide which I can take
on c7 Queen HP check and King you won
Bishop before I have 93 fortunately
otherwise I'm just worse here look
tonight
nice history right nice so you played
Bishop c5 good move
yeah kingi - and I mean I see that the
engine gives hero 24 white but it's just
yeah if you if you try to exchange
Queens that's Queen G for example huh
yeah you just have to go back too many
witnesses
yeah and the Bishop on c5 is too strong
okay interesting very very interesting
game I mean yeah so it looks like it
looks looks like you guys drop pretty
interesting game so congratulations but
why you playing next I bring some
leagues now and no strong tournament you
know in the short future
okay later this year interesting very
nice okay well good luck in the around
tomorrow I still have one more want to
go and so good luck thank you doing us
and we are going to take a commercial
break and we are going to come back
later
[Music]
professional Twitter from dem ass I
should not have pronounced that that was
a bit of a champion for those of you who
are new to chess it might look like VA 3
is an illegal move here because white
advances pawn to square is not one but
it still is something we call hustle and
you can do that you have to do it
instantly you can't wait for a move like
that say play King in seven Kingi - and
I'll try because y'all play four against
Lawrence and now he's going to play
something against me which we discussed
the playing during the course of my
steak yeah he told me this is that d5
this was what I was kind of hoping for
because now I think we finally know who
Lawrence this is not how she has works
certainly would be much much more fun if
Chester to work like this I don't think
it does
well maybe it does well that's me
regretting what I just said how did I
get from there to here is a little bit
beyond me
and what's worse I will never hear the
end of it my quality of life has just
gone downhill tremendously because I'm
actually sharing the office with the guy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
as the st. Louis chess club celebrates
its 10th anniversary the US
Championships returned to st. Louis for
the 10th straight year
this April America's best players
descend on st. Louis to play for the
country's top honor Wesley so and sabina
Poyser will be defending their
championships as they face an all-star
field
don't miss America's best battle it out
at the st. Louis chess club celebrating
10 years of promoting teaching and
playing the game of chess for tickets
and more information go to st. Louis
chess club or be surprised be intrigued
the world chess Hall of Fame in st.
Louis is nothing you'd expect and
everything you love three galleries
highlight the history culture and
creativity behind the game explore chess
in ways you never imagined it's a
one-of-a-kind cultural institution where
rare artifacts and world-class art play
together the world chess Hall of Fame
mind art experience and we're back here
for coverage of round number eight of
the 2018 spring chess classic I'm Ben
Simon and I have a thought in a Murr and
during our interview we had another
result by tallying all right we had that
crazy game yeah Alexander eepa table has
drawn his game and black against Sam
Shanklin it seems like there is a lots
of violence on the chest wall today but
he just like everybody is just coming
back peacefully Yeah right and we
thought this this was gonna be the game
there'd be something happening there'd
be a 1 and there'd be a 0 yeah not the
case but they'll fighting right a nice
chess okay sounds good so what do we
have left well in Group A Darryl spirits
and Lazaro brew zone is the last game in
progress and actually if Darla looks
like he's in pretty good shape if
Darwins
and then he wins tomorrow and Jeffrey
loses then darl can share first place
long shot still you know with Jeffrey
have to come back with a zero tomorrow
but yeah an important game nonetheless
yeah very interesting actually this
position of Israel imbalanced
I would assume it probably came from the
Sicilian just by the look of the the
Kings you know again this opposite side
Catholic and that we have seen here
right now white is leaving with a let's
see we have a rope and a pawn versus a
knight so it's definitely a material
advantage for white white is also there
is living on the clock with 30 minutes
mate time control just made time control
okay let's let's go first the word
so actually this is Britain's third xxx
movie
I do believe okay so Siderius already
got 40 minutes and now it's prisons move
well obviously he has enough time to
make his 40th move so it's not another
time pressure and I think that he did
make a movie did play Knight to e7 going
backwards I gotta tell it but once I see
you know such moves when somebody is
playing going backwards in such
positions it's not a good sign just not
a good sign though is you feel feel like
you have no space so let's see what can
I do here with white can I put my rope
somewhere obviously the rook is attacked
I can't I cannot prove the roof to d7
for example I don't want to blunder my
knight accidentally so route to e5 might
be played just to keep the rook here on
the fifth-ranked
looking under all those knights
defending the knight on d5 and I wonder
if black is planning to go back with a
knight interesting so what I do this
rook where do I put it
I mean I can go back here but then I
assume that Y does not want to draw over
there such an advantage very interesting
what about sacrificing let's go crazy
for a second f5 I'm seeing my Queen here
in front of the screen f5 now the knight
can take on d5 Oh
lots of calculations what if I just take
the silent on e6 and now I'm cutting and
mate on f7 what we like to do then hmm
so the rook who can cook and defend this
pawn
they that's that's good that's probably
a very tough position for black just
because I'm all he's also going to lose
this knight on d5 the next move Knight
to f4 will probably not help because of
going to d4 it looks like I'm invading
into blacks camp it's gonna be
interesting to see what is gonna be
played in this in this moment right now
easy is dahlias gonna play this over f5
or not always going to go back to e5 but
then Knights back to c6 that's the
position that we have seen before
what else can we play here what about 96
96 and if it takes a rope can I think
it's rock
then he has some kind of a 94 check and
then the queen is going to take on c8
this is very complicated position yeah
let's see let's see how it happened
perform the opening fo was played c5 I
feel like most of the games they will
play d4 so interesting
c5 the Sicilian Knight f3 d6 d4 let's
see what kind of acid syria what
variation we have we have the neither f
a 6 Bishop g5 one of the main moves 97
there's so much dealer here in this and
this this line it's pretty incredible
just to study this the knight of will
take us in on some weeks every month
right yes that's the rolls-royce of
chess openings yeah definitely Bishop e3
e6 I assume that this was quite a theory
while with the old lines black is
attacking the King side King side white
is attacking on the like black is
attacking of the Queen side white stuff
attacking on the King side Bishop late
to be 8 B 4 okay well that's a bit
unusual this move before but on the
other hand black is playing to play B
for himself now if you kind of pay
attention here black did not castle yet
he's just waiting to see what what he's
going to do it's kind of like a waiting
game
it doesn't want does not want to
indicate the fact that okay well I'm I
cancelled here or here you go you can
push all your pawns and pretty much do
the same thing as that with a Yugoslav
attack so he keeps his King in the
center just for a while feeling pretty
comfortable and b4 usually I don't like
such was like before because obviously
we we really weaken our King 83 square C
3 square the King feels a bit
it's a bit shady so about nine to be
seven Bishop to e3 I assumed that this
was still some kind of a whole
population King to b2 and looks like
white has defended all those weaknesses
and finally black castles h4 and a five
yeah these positions are always very
complicated even if all four engines and
computers stay sometimes they don't
understand when we sacrifice a pawn or
positional advantage very very sharp
line g5 9 h5 90s b5 going to be eight I
like that the Queen here is aligned for
the King and now Knight to a7 Wow okay
so let's see why can't we take this
night when you just are just completely
undefended well the fact is that that
night now the Queen is aligned just with
the bishop so any Knight move Oedipus in
the position is going to be a discovered
attack the only question is where do I
want to see my knight I do see that this
bishop on e7 is undefended so why can't
a Knight a5 or 96 to attack this Bishop
let's go here let's move the Queen away
somewhere and now Knight taking on e6
forking the the king and the rook and
it's gonna take you on c8 just just
gives me a headache just to calculate
all those variations and this is just
one of them
so obviously black did not take on they
say 0 c7 and then other night comes to
b5 so now not only attacking the rook
here on c7 but also eyeballing this pawn
on d6 and defending the knight on 87 so
more and more I like white and it's
quite quite unusual but white is the one
who is attacking on the Queen side very
unusual
is attacking here on the Queen side and
then Bishop takes b5 they exchanges the
few pieces
Knight to d8 and now Queen e8 we have a
few maneuvering moves 22 d 5f or so
still wide is looking to push on the
King side take take unfortunately I
think that in this case but just that
doesn't have enough pieces here
missed the King so but he does try
result that that is trying to create
some kind of play for black maybe six go
into f2 Bishop a5 Bishop c5
and Bishop takes f8 King takes f8 taking
on e6 so let's jump to our current
position let me just refresh our game
here so this is the current position
right now in the game so black just made
this move is 97 and White has a lot of
time to think he has 22 minutes but
remember that that is pretty much it
just Y just got the get and got the time
control with an extra half a half an
hour so I wouldn't be spending as much
time with white on this situation all
right we're going to come back to this
interesting game but right now we have a
special guest with us Alexander I bet oh
yeah welcome thank you very interesting
game that you played today
yeah so let's let's look at the game I
know that first of all know everybody
was discussing the first move over the
board yes Ben actually was mentioning
that he was at the playing hall when you
were there and you were thinking for
five minutes
yes on the same is known for his opening
preparation and I just wanted to play
interesting chess good I don't play nice
and I mean they want to show like cause
it organizers and just not play for draw
nice every ever seen this move before
yes just yeah it was just thinking
you're trying to pick and move I mean
like c6 96 96 immediately well maybe if
I was interesting so you just random
stuff over the board okay very very
interesting probably probably night h6
won't be as good because yeah yeah okay
interesting so I was always so nice
after I saw this move on it's time to
research the name of this opening and I
couldn't find it but I gave it a name
and you let me know what they think
about I called it the drunken night
defense enjoy okay
hey up room I I haven't I haven't seen
actually I haven't to research this more
but it's gonna be very interesting to
see it might be the first but the first
one was definitely who is
to play by a grandmaster yeah you might
have lots of followers afterwards think
ok if you played before I mean I thought
the place to six the first move
even here the same thing again I hope
they see six and the thing is Bishop a
625 no that's actually what I was
mentioning when I looked at it so why
didn't fly play before with the idea of
taking on ace yes that was my
preparation for Tomas but after c4 I was
out of books a queen a5 and yeah it
might be better yeah he shouldn't take
it but that is before I try to justify
him of 96 somehow how was his reaction
after yes daisies I think he felt a bit
disrespectful but yeah yeah
you have nothing to lose right it's
almost almost the 8th round so you're
playing fighting chess yeah I mean I - -
but I mean I think I played some
creative in fighting chess I mean I lost
two games but in both games I tried to
get something more and yeah I was
because I was yeah yeah very good so he
played the c4 c5 I don't know
he's fine yeah it should be objectively
correct of course but just the practical
game and he has to find the wolves
yeah there is a psychological factor
that he finds it is just disrespectful
and he might get angry and play some
over aggressive moves and so yeah
interesting
ok so it took so he took only five like
d6 yeah so this was so this there is
such a sacrifice d5 and an e5 right
immediately the though some such opening
right if you prefer yeah d5 d4 and an e5
yeah I think Christian Christian Camilla
played against me in place right so he
should be different because the United
six badly placed action because after
what played c4 I want to jump to before
maybe in the pond system is protected
yeah yeah let me just try here
that's a good question
I've never used this option before okay
flipping the board but we'll try to
figure this out I want to challenge you
to see how white felt how do you play
guessed 96 if you do game yeah so d6 and
they played night of three so it was
fine so I need for Bishop if I spend
like another like 15 minutes Queen d7
and 93 I think I have to take because I
mean I would love to play some like
useful no but I don't have any useful
move because if I develop a piece he
will just take Bishop e7 and he'll be
much better and I thank you so take
Queen takes and Bishop takes and
although you do get to an end game with
a pawn down but as you said this night
might come to before wish it to be for
you Oh Bishop to before you also have
some right now if six is coming
sometimes first and then my idea was to
play of six and win the pawn back but
then I realized he might be just better
in the game so for example he played f6
here he plays Knight f3
so if six here sorry Bishop a4 f6 f6
here that's right
Bishop takes before and long castle and
I think it's just yeah slightly better
for white wants to play E for mm-hmm
yeah so this was not what I wanted to
get them in not allow him to castle do
not avoid the castle yes I want to get
something like that I would have played
some other opening and try to suffer put
them in my da was not to suffer but just
to play super creative game we have in
this chess tournament so castle and III
Knight of 6 but I think very interesting
way I spend like another 20 to 25
minutes here I couldn't figure out what
to do I had moved up g5 but he just
plays Bishop g3 instead of human
fine they should be stretched great
witnesses from his house so he cannot
take because yes luckily maybe he can
take but why to do that right so g5 and
ambition would you - yeah he wants to
play Knight f3 and that 125 is attacked
in 94 I mean yeah do you have any kind
of chances to maybe h5 well that's too
much
I think it's for its for may be very
shouts out game yeah I mean I have to be
careful because I might just get the row
into positions interesting so 9 f6 was
played Bishop e2 and now Bishop before
yeah it's it's quite equally guess but
[Music]
and then you took on City which was a
very good move mm it takes and now 90
force a real lawyer this I guess
positional compensation yeah it's just
fantastic position because he's pieces
are the play 925 and Bishop and if we're
not playing I was saying from this
moment on actually from all of your game
you always played forward with all of
the pieces are you like that yeah like
in this game that's give me exhibition
especially with it with the rook coming
in through d8 so okay so let's see so
what was PlayStation 3 I think I should
have played night AC 5
night ac5 I'm bringing the other night
to the game yeah so someone has to take
take and play f3 but I think up there 3
I have maybe a six simply yeah but it
looks like both of the uppity girl I
mean this rock on D - yeah even I
creating some chaos so if it's a mistake
they can well it's interesting
yeah well it's how it's hot okay others
this is not so obvious because I'd like
but what happens we have six instead of
95 here yeah surprise another fun but
yeah those this pawn structure is quite
funny
you can probably not take here I'll take
because I would have played this
position but the thing is that I didn't
play it because of some other line
because of Knight f3
see it's obvious 79f threated even hear
me
I was thinking f2g 595 years like 94
check yeah this life is beautiful yeah I
think he was just too busking f3m kinky
- yeah if I get this position
it was my knight on e4 and the shippin
safe where I think like it's close to
winning them right why it's close are
you yes but because of concrete reasons
I mean my king f3m king it - yeah and I
cannot get what I want a man if the only
you can only get the night and see for
not a bishop on see yeah but yeah if for
maybe or something yeah very interesting
game I mean you have so many options
yeah have to choose sometimes if the
clock is ticking yes and I make a move
and there's been a lot of time on the
first couple of most of time to play
because I like my position at the 94 but
I don't think I played the right most
interesting so you play they said f5
which I like in the gammy you you still
want to control the light squares yeah
but after that I can't play f6 and like
that attack his Knight okay but I
thought maybe his night is out of 25
yeah so you play Bishop g3 preparing
against g5 I guess maybe it was gathered
about g5 he wants to protect upon left
to play Bishop t1 f3 or something like
the knight hd8 I mean that I really like
destructive now who comes to the 6b 6b -
yeah but I felt like I lost coordination
a little bit so then I was a bit angry
at myself that I didn't play the move
what we just looked so Bishop to h4 yeah
I think he defended well here although a
thing of the bishop is seven rupees six
this would happened maybe hadn't robbed
d1 here yeah and then repeat 293 he had
to play Knight to d3
I don't know I mean
yeah just going back yes that's what the
petition I saw so I was very angry
because I didn't pose any problems but
what happened also good for me I think
so take take my roof tasty too rook
takes D - yeah
King a fun king of next year have a
choice my things
yeah now it's time to bring the knight
back yes didn't go to c5 this looks very
Jewish but in fact the man I think I
could have proposed more problems right
because it really on c2 yeah and he
needs to find the right now it was a
political bishops I mean pawns are not
so important I mean it's about like
controlling squares and passed pawns in
activity also of course 9797
take take and rotate before before you
and now I find an interesting idea a5
yeah I repeated most just to just to get
some time because I mean I lost my boss
my game sometime trouble here I was
looking at the game live and I said well
it's very good that you did not accept
the drawing I still applies yeah very
nice I'll get back to school I mean like
in today so I want to enjoy as much as I
can
yeah so a5 and the rook h4 and I assume
let's hear you were trying to figure out
how do you and I have time but I think
was bit dangerous what he did because I
mean I think f4 and we do some talk
matter the game to throw page 7 b6 yeah
he's told me Rob b8 I think yeah I had
Kings mystics no check first in YouTube
and then kimchi 66
it does look very dangerous right here
yeah and then I just want to wish Bishop
it's excellent
hi I'm take on c4 I thought I mean it's
lost for wait I mean close to look what
she said hmm I just missed him in this
idea because I won't always want to play
c5 and the King King says six is just
stands on the way over the pond but I
didn't realize it I mean I want to play
Bishop is steak and then different story
yeah yeah computer actually the CSA's
bug is much better so maybe in practical
game yeah so instead you Bishop e6
immediately yeah
so let's see what's the difference I
just miss the city of to exchange works
and now we have to exchange rooks for
sure if I can exchange hooks I will win
one pawn bag it's a check you know 64
you want and you're trying to keep the
motherboard but yes persistent yeah this
way I had to play King's just examine
and then he doesn't have that yeah sir
okay one yeah they just disappeared the
most agreed for a draw
afterwards yeah very very interesting
game very creative yeah who are you
playing next environment from friends of
mine yeah they also put have a pretty
good game today and yeah you said you go
to school here right yeah I got some
diversity as well okay have some
teammates with you guys here playing the
same to lemon yeah except Francesco
everyone is playing Francesca I'm
Bradley he's focused on school but
everyone else is here yeah how do you
how do you usually manage you know
schoolwork and chess tournaments well
during school I was completely focused
on school now during tournament it was a
bit difficult to get back to chest
because I haven't played for a long time
so that's why I've been suffered here
try to play creative chest but I mean
time trouble I was just always missing
something and losing yeah yeah in terms
of like creativity am satisfied was my
play I mean the quality of games just
accept just
I think it was not intentional nice and
what's your major by the way and being
yeah I have graduated in May from I also
have an MBA but yeah so maybe you open a
business one day the thing is to put a
business nowadays I mean there is no
need to have it be right yeah MP it's a
very interesting story man like two
hundred thousand two degrees like
granted every year right and I think I
mean just the quality of education
everything across all countries is just
dropping mmm mmm yeah MBA just is not
impeded it used to be like 40 years ago
right no way
nowadays everyone could even get an MBA
just matter of taking a loan and paying
paid for next 20 years
yeah depends I mean some here some of
there is a couple of years I mean I
guess it depends on the school but
you're from Turkey right I'm from
Ukraine Ukraine get you I play turkey
but I'm originally I say so how was it
for you to come in here and say to st.
Louis big change or I like traveling
it's just it's okay for me whenever I am
I mean I don't really feel different
turkey Ukraine Spain I mean America yeah
and we with the chest list kind of get
used to the the the hotel life I guess I
don't like yeah yes I'm quite
insensitive okay interesting well thank
you so much for joining us today
good luck in your next round I'm
actually gonna be very curious what
movie would you choose with white
tomorrow
please surprises prefer to put some
pressure Minh okay I think that night a
six put a lot of pressure today
very creative game so thank you so much
for joining us and we are going to go
into a short commercial break and we're
gonna come after
a moment comes in chess when you need to
test yourself at a different level chess
24 premium offers the tools that you
need to reach your maximum potential
from hundreds of interactive video
lessons to becoming part of the chess 24
community you can analyze with friends
or coach your students live you get
twenty four by seven coverage of chest
news and events access to premium
analysis and commentary and the chance
to interact with grandmasters and other
top players and coaches get advised from
the best and even challenged them to a
battle be the best chess player you can
be it's time to level up your game with
just 24 Premium Membership
as the st. Louis chess club celebrates
its 10th anniversary the US
Championships returned to st. Louis for
the 10th straight year
this April America's best players
descend on st. Louis to plate for the
country's top honor Wesley so and Sabina
Pfizer will be defending their
championships as they face an all-star
field
don't miss America's best battle it out
at the st. Louis chess club celebrating
10 years of promoting teaching and
playing the game of chess for tickets
and more information go to st. Louis
chess club org
[Music]
be surprised be intrigued be delighted
the world chess Hall of Fame in st.
Louis is nothing you'd expect and
everything you love three galleries
highlight the history culture and
creativity behind the game explore chess
in ways you never imagined it's a
one-of-a-kind cultural institution where
rare artifacts and world-class art play
together the world chess Hall of Fame
mind art experience
and welcome back to coverage for the
2018 spring chess classic it's the
penultimate round round the braid my
name is Ben Simon I matter if I thought
a namer we want to thank Alex ich baton
for coming in and sharing his thoughts
on that strange and yet oddly aggressive
first move oh yeah that's funny very
exciting well I'm I'm one be very
excited to see what he's gonna play for
us tomorrow
vitaliy you said that there is a couple
of exciting games oh yeah definitely so
let's let's jump into it let's start
with the game of the day in Group B Alex
Victor Michalowski versus Aaron grabbed
in ski so we left before with the game
we said it to a white head two pieces
for oak he's white still has two pieces
for a rope and black has now rope and
upon however you know Ben usually in end
games the rook sometimes is much more
effective than two pieces not sure why
but usually when the rook just slides
behind the pawn and just supports its
way all the way through and just the
knife and the bishop don't have the same
coordination between them so in this
case both they are made the main time
control 45 goals have have been played
and it's always on the on the lead all
the time however now it is Victor's move
and I wonder if he's going to play this
off
rook to a7 or what about this move maybe
route to b6 can he play this move well
actually not because of 98 share so
there's there are some threats that
white is creating that's a fork exactly
and we don't want to be get forked no no
that's the objective yeah so can i play
rook a7 here
I can't okay seven and just start
pushing my porn well I can't Poli but
it's not gonna be so easy because still
the whites bishop here is defending here
on a four and they look as well
maybe wife can just play something like
king king g4 and
attack those pawns let's try something
else
what about this move a for a wonder if
black can play this move immediately
they root can I take on 84 because I'm
going to lose my bishop the bishop can I
take on a4 because I am going to lose my
rogue
not exactly my rook but oh you feel that
he's gonna get for y'all gonna get both
again yeah otherwise you don't get a
fork right yeah yeah all you have to do
it's really not that hard vitality is
just not getting formed yeah that's a
show here that you're the same yes
actually it's called don't get forth
yeah and in this game of course we're
not playing right in Chester's game so
this is not getting for ya so so a four
would be an interesting move obviously
in this case black cannot play
I'm sorry wife cannot play this move
Knight he ate with a fork because we
just stick it we just take the knight
and we are actually cannot take the rook
because we are pinned yes
so I wonder if there is if those unusual
coming don't get pinned well it looks
like your Biscay might not be a good
contender either yeah yeah so it's gonna
be interesting to see that so French the
board just in case to see if game was
played from oval States so no not yet
interesting game if Victor wins this
game this is what I almost secured his
know if Victor wins this game he will be
first much like Geoffrey now he will
secure at least a tie for first there
are no playoffs if he's gonna have six
points right six points and there's
well hey buddy an Encana pan you know
that I've misspoke in this book their
games are not over yet so no it's he
would not secure anything with only a
win yet yeah well let's let's then jump
to that game the game of of the day in
Group B catchin vs can upon let's see
what we have here
Wow well first of all PD is leading with
three pawns up that's that's almost like
a piece of a piece but definitely black
will not stand by and just watch lose
the game so probably he's gonna try to
annoy a white by checking him to check
now if the King will go to see two black
has this option by playing rook to c2 e
check this is gonna be very strong for
black if akka I try to come to be too
well I really don't want to put my king
in front of this Bishop and now we have
a bunch of discovered checks such as
roof takes on c4 and I feel like this
will not be white choice so if we go
backwards if you go a little bit to that
position that we have on the board
if black checks on h3 white let's see
how can I defend how can I defend really
check well as we say the best defense is
offense so I'm gonna play King efore and
if the rook is takes on bt i wanna check
him
King takes has to take and our King
takes on e5
well this end game now with ants pose
into it rooks endgame and even though
black for example can get this pawn on
d5 if I get this this pawn on g6 with my
king those protected passed pawns a pair
of passed pawns are going to easily win
the game for white there is no chance
for any kind of for draw so I think that
right now Malik is thinking he is I
thought at this position and is thinking
oh my god how can I save this so canna
pan has right now four points four and a
half four and a half so if PD will win
this game he's gonna be at five and a
half and that means that still the first
place will not be decided correct
yeah so this is a big game here this
could be a big one for priyadarshan as
far as the final standings go no let's
see do we have any games left in Group A
we do we have
Lazaro Brazil versus Darius Ritz and we
left last time in this position when
black has played this move Knight to e7
attacking the rook was played three five
nine to c6 they go back and forth back
and forth Knight to e7 and now why
decides no okay I'm gonna I don't want
to draw I mean I may I'm gonna change up
and he played Queen three three giving
away this his exchange nine takes on d5
real take is d5 and white is a pawn up
however his King slightly I would say
maybe more exposed I mean the Queen here
is just a follow the King Bishop to b6
and now why destroyed Queen to e4 very
interesting position if it was black
Tove in two games comment or me bless
you it is a bit dusty here right yeah
Queen to e4 and now black can either
take on it for with the night or the
queen or I'm most also looking at this
move Knight to c5 just forking everybody
it's all about the forks today so let's
try to make a move let's start to take
with the Queen Queen takes Queen takes
Knight eggs and let's look at this
position the rook is being attacked Road
d7
and there is the black is going to
experience some problem here with the
pawn on f7 even after 96 this will not
help you because of 96 or some
sacrifices for example route takes f7
and 96
the King has to move somewhere and I'm
going to take here on c8 that does not
look so promising for black
so like right now he's thinking how
should I play here and by the way so
Brazil has more time on the clock if you
can see from from the live video it's
kind of covering his ears maybe both of
them is kind of covering is just usually
some chess players like to use this
tactic as well as for myself just in
case if there's some kind of a noise
coming out coming in but it's really
quiet you know the Chess Club it's
pretty quiet up there yeah they're
playing in a and what we call the
boardroom here and the boardroom is
actually a very versatile room here at
the club if you come and get a tour it
may not look the same one time to
another it's not only do they have board
meetings here with the st. Louis chess
club but also that's where the
Sinquefield cup is played the st. Louis
rapid and blitz the very best in the
world sometimes we have open tournaments
we'll have the top boards in the
boardroom because it's the nicest it's
not always the best well lit as we can
see it's it doesn't look at that dark in
there I promise you some of the boards
have lamps on them though if they're in
darker areas of the room but it is the
the swankiest room of the chess club I
will tell you that oh definitely I know
that for myself after the main chest was
before and this is probably the most
unique chess club you know lots of
conditions you know very good chair is
very comfortable lots of light light
coming in very nice boards dgt boards
you sometimes just like the feeling of
the wood sort of the sort of the regular
plastic snacks the clothes you get some
snacks I got some dried mangoes or
something up there to fancy yeah drinks
even you know you can even take some
some redbull or some coffee do players I
know it's not as many players as one
might think during coffee during a game
day a game does that give them like a
jitters or anything like that
I think the caffeine makes you go
through the restroom a lot ok but which
we have many restaurants that's not a
problem but sometimes during time
pressure it might become a problem
yeah and these two players in particular
spirits and burrs own have a equal
lifetime record against each other there
are no strangers they've played for
classical games two draws and two
decisive games for both players and
they've also played two played in rats
and rapid and blitz games as well the
world rapid championship they had a draw
millionaire chess Maurice Ashley's a big
tournament that he organized a few years
ago he had three editions of those they
played there one year and actually last
year at the Spring Classic with the
colors reversed the game was a draw
between these two so no strangers to
each other yeah yeah some some some
players when they compete against each
other they just draw the times yeah
high-level players right here yeah okay
so we are going to come back to this
game let's jump in to back to group B
who else do we have we haven't discussed
the this game jack stem black versus
Alexander fear have that touch this game
yet they have a 12 number 62 and just
look at the time immediately I can see
that jack is getting to that time
pressure on normal thirty minutes just
playing on increment and that those six
minutes and it's under fear with fifty
five minutes wow that's a 50 minute
advantage over there that's really nice
you can definitely like something you
can definitely afford it himself just to
grab a coffee or take some time so let's
see what's going on here so Queen after
you was played in the game let's try to
exchange Queens and see what happens so
right now in this position is gonna be a
white is upon up now if black manages to
exchange the rooks take the middle of
the board then we will see pretty easy
draw for black in my opinion because we
have the
we have the opposite color bishops on
the board however it is not so easy for
y2b
to exchange the rooks absolutes for
black oh let's try to play this move
rook to d8 attacking this this this pawn
d5 pawn takes and I assume I have to
take to the bishop because again if I
take with the Queen with the rook the
rook is gonna take me back
so roof takes on Bishop takes on d5 now
as white I kept my pieces on the board
but the problem is what am I going to do
next I mean this Bishop is on d5 is
pinned the rook has to defend the bishop
so what am I going to I'm gonna have to
bring my king in but it is black to move
so I wonder what to do if black manages
to exchange all the pawns there may be
sacrifices a bishop for the last-born
well that's a theoretical draw we have
gonna have a real coup versus a rook in
the bishop so that might be one of the
ideas if I'm doing my King here to f8
dingy to King is 7 King f3 what are the
next okay that's what make a wedding
with Bishop c5 kingi for now if I bring
my king to e4 to defend the bishop on d5
now I'm planning to move my rogue
somewhere to slide it to a 1 or 2 b1 and
to b7 well now I left all of my pawns
undefended especially the spoiler g3
which is the base of the pawn chain and
let's see can black play Bishop to f2
trying to annoy us in that case white
might bring his King backwards and it
might drop so that's just just
speculation so let's so fudge the ball
that see what happened in the game in
the game black decided not to exchange
the cannot exchange the Queen's right
Queen to be
interesting so black is continued
continue his fight now wants to take you
on d4 I would assume white will at some
point will have to push this pawn to d5
the only question here is can Blake
manage and play something like rout the
city I mean I'm getting slightly worried
about the skin on HD still not not too
much because we have row to D to e this
this King feels a little bit more unsafe
than the blacking so it's gonna be
interesting to see what will happen in
this game let's jump back to our game of
day a victim Michalowski versus Erin
grab in skeet
we will left it in this position why
proxy for him I said black could have
been played a for maybe when he said
black played came to h6 and that is to
defend the pawn on d5 just in case and
bring the King out of the forks so
Viktor definitely does not want to get
fork today
yes so King h6 night to b5 was played
Roxy to eat c8 and now it is white to
move it's very difficult here to for
right to play first of all the chances
for white to win here I'm almost almost
there almost none I mean at some point
those pawns are going to be exchanged
and it's gonna be super difficult if we
change one of the routes that's that's
pretty much it there's no chance in for
Y to win but there are definitely
chances here for black to win this
position so let's try to make a move but
if I go back with a 936 maybe who goes
to c7 I think we had a move here was
played in the game let's afresh the
board
and Ruth - BT check was played okay
always will go forward now it's white to
move so let's see what is the idea if
King is going to g4 what am i doing with
my rock my rock b8 but if I play will be
hidden Knight f7 might sound like my
take on g5
very interesting
- OH - bTW check now
it is why to move almost looks like from
the video that it's Victor's move almost
of that he is the one who is more
concentrated in the game but no it's
Aaron's move he's just taking taking his
time I think about what the position is
probably thinking okay where should I
move working forward or backwards it's a
big decision usually would like to move
it forward but maybe there are some
tricks that black has prepared for white
yeah judging from the body language it
is a little reversed Aaron just reached
for his king but then had second
thoughts
yeah well he can he can touch the camera
probably the move will be made by the
king right the Oni oh I see it going
backwards right so King went to g2 good
it's a small win for black because now a
white king went backwards is cut so the
king is not in the game which gives
black black some some some chances to
play king h5 every ng fall in the future
but right now black needs to figure out
well am I putting the stroke on c8 what
I put I mean I can put it on well d8 I'm
going to get fork so I gotta be careful
how the rook c7 I would say win the row
back and maybe we're gonna see again
night to b5 but if I if white is trying
to play this move Knight d5 black has a
small trick here rook takes rook takes
take a knight
however if I remember correctly this end
game might end in a draw if if White was
the rookie on a six I'm not sure that
black can win this usually in such any
end games even with the apron and the
Jeep on white succeeds in making a draw
even without the put this pawns on g6
and the a6
so if King h5 then rook aah
and when I'm going to come here to meet
the black king from from behind and
actually is gonna be a mate if I'm gonna
playing oak which is going to be a maid
so let's start you to check us and again
they check us again King G - yeah this
is gonna be this is going to be a draw
so maybe this trick is not working into
blacks favor
this is gonna be a long a long game I
always say that but it might be a long
game let's see let's see who else do we
have we have any kind of developments
let's look at the game of the day
medic Aegean against PD as we said black
did take Luke H 3 and now PD didn't king
efore went on the offense and black
played Bishop to b2 defending from this
threat of c5 check but I really like
what's positioned more and more I really
think that black has no almost no chance
to save this game I probably need to
move a bishop somewhere the question is
where my first line of thought is to
play Bishop to a4 maybe Bishop to EA
they just grabbed this pawn on d6 once I
grab this pawn g6 really there's almost
no way for life to to stop all those
pawns or it's only 4 points up and to be
honest I cannot see how black tries to
create any counter play you can play
Roxy 3 but then I can play either it
check walking just defend with the
bishop and there okay Mike down to h6
and we can take this followed u6
I like white white odds on in here yeah
it looks like priyadarshan is is in
position to take the live lead I stress
the word live right yes it'll still be
up there but nice ok so we have one game
left in Group A still dark spirits and
Lazaro zone and then we have three games
still going on in Group B
I think we glanced at all of them oh
yeah they're fun thing and I think that
none of them will end soon it's it's all
kind of an end game games all of them
are after move 40 which gives them some
extra time to play and it's exciting
it's a sign because we can see that
people are still fighting even it's
round number eight right well these
players they're gonna play for a little
bit longer and our time is drawing nigh
now tomorrow we will be on as long as it
takes to see the winner crowned and or
winners crowned in the event of a tie
because there's no playoffs but in the
interim let's take a look at the
standings so far in Group A there is one
game still remaining and yeah Jeffrey's
at the top var is at the top and either
darl and Lazaro if one of them wins
they're at four and a half so they're
gonna shoot right up that right up the
charts there the players are really
close together I mean it looks like
Jeffrey at the top it's really staggered
far but the players are really still
grouped together quite close
I don't know has a chance yes and it all
rides on the games tomorrow these are
gonna be the final round pairings for
our masters division okay
so Jeffrey Zhang will be meeting Alex or
Ashok eepa table and Edouard good games
here abre zone and a Cobian that could
be important yeah that might be even the
game of the day conveniences are
relieved if if Brazil wins they both
gonna have four and a half points and
that might be that might be the game
that which decide for the second or
third place yeah yeah for sure
and in our challengers division let's
glance at the standings here that I mean
there's still three games going you
can't get too much out of this but here
they are yeah so we have victim
Michalowski
and on
Egorov it's at the top with five points
and then we have Malik Cochin and Playa
- I can upon which are facing each other
right now with four and a half points
very very strong very very strong
competition at the top and we said that
the victim ahead of scheme might have a
chance to win although it might end in a
draw so he will probably be in the lead
with five and a half all six points
after him other governments and many
kitchen is playing priyadarshan
production looks pretty good with those
advantage of three points he might win
his play his game so he will be with
five and a half and either tying with
Victor on the second spot and they were
gonna have on the core of it so very
very tight and not not sure man who's
gonna be on top after this run we could
okay I mean this might be one of those
situations where we kind of wish we did
have a playoff let's take a look at the
games that we have set for tomorrow
remember they do begin a little bit
earlier two hours earlier than the first
eight rounds this is what we have to
offer here yeah and I think that the
game of the day might be a medic at Xian
versus Andre gore Vidal over there at
the top competing for one of the first
places specifically in Group B vitality
what do you think the chances are that
we're going to have Co champions in
first place at the end of round nine
yeah chances are pretty big pretty big I
mean I have a buddy there at the top and
we might have a tie and in that case we
just did the price yeah split the prize
a lot of people go home happy yeah we'll
come back later
so this broadcast was produced by the
world's greatest B team Tammy Hyde is
our technical advisor
Jonathan France was getting our
interviews today Isaac sprouts is on
sound and graphics our technical
director is danny Machuca my name is Ben
Simon and I'm without a murmur and
remember tomorrow the games begin at 11
a.m. central on us chess champs calm we
will begin our broadcast of the final
round
at 1:30 p.m. and we're going to talk to
all the winners it's going to be a huge
shebang a lot of fun
so until then we say so long from the
show-me-state
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you
you